you know what's funny to me I spent
almost $200 on a pencil what's going on
guys my name is David Thomas and welcome
back to the channel today we're talking
about the Apple pencil and specifically
why the Apple pencil is any good should
you go out and spend 200 Australian
dollars on what's basically just an
overpriced stylist or should you just go
out and buy any old stylists maybe one
of those $20 wish replacements well
let's find out so if you were to spend
almost 200 Australian dollars or about
120 US on Apple pencil what do you
really get it doesn't matter if you
purchase the generation 1 like I have
here or the second generation that works
with the iPad pro the unboxing
experience is pretty much exactly the
same inside when you pull the little tab
you don't see the pencil straightaway
which is a little bit of a shame because
when you unbox an iPhone you see exactly
what you're purchased and what you're
really wanting to see inside the box but
instead with this one you get a few
little pamphlets some instructions a
charger an extra tip and that's pretty
much it and then underneath we have the
actual Apple pencil itself so it comes
straight out it's wrapped in a little
bit of plastic that you can quickly
unseal and that's all there is all it is
is one very precisely engineered pencil
you may be wondering why I'm making this
video years after the original Apple
pencil came out or several months after
the second-generation pencil came out
well the answer guys is very simple if
you've been following my channel for a
while now you're gonna know that I've
recently started using some Apple
products I've purchased a couple iPads
couple pencils and everything that you
can really get I've even started using
an iMac for my work purposes yes there
is a desktop set up behind me but this
is my home office so I've started to
kind of embrace the Apple ecosystem a
bit more
and in my personal experience I think
there's some things that need to be said
about the Apple pencil and the need to
be addressed about all stylists in
general so what differentiates apples
pencil at 200 Australian dollars from a
twenty dollar wish item that's really
cheap nasty and you're probably gonna
lose and have to buy another one and not
worry too much about well that's a
relatively simple question again the
Apple ecosystem is designed to hook you
in and make you buy these products when
you buy an Apple pencil first-generation
it's actually a bit of a pain in the
butt to set up you have to plug it in
you have to sync it it's it's not very
user-friendly unlike all the new Apple
products that come out when you unbox it
it automatically pops up on your screen
and you kind of feel welcomed into their
ecosystem you don't get the same
experience with this pencil I know you
do with the second-generation Apple
pencil and with an iPad pro so that is
taken completely off the negative side
of things when you purchase a
second-generation pencil however some of
the best things about this pencil is the
simple connect ability the compatibility
with all the apps and the relative ease
of use once it is connected it doesn't
have a very large battery inside it but
because it doesn't use a lot of power it
isn't constantly connected it knows when
it's asleep it knows when it's awake it
actually retains as a battery life
pretty well I think I charged mine once
a week and I use it on a daily basis and
even when you do charge it within about
5 10 minutes of it charging it's gone
from zero to 100 pretty quickly so from
that alone the battery itself isn't too
big but it doesn't take a long time to
charge so it isn't a huge negative or a
huge burden that you have to plug it in
the bottom whereas with the Apple
generation 2 pencil automatic of charges
or when it snaps on to the top and locks
into place it doesn't slip away from
your iPad like this one does is an added
extra benefit but if we're being real
here with ourselves guys you can
probably go out and buy a $20 stylist no
problems whatsoever
because the difference between a first
generation Apple pencil and any hold
stylist off the block besides
static appearances there isn't really
too much I think the main point of
difference for me personally is the
simple fact of how the Apple pencil
charges yes it's not the prettiest thing
in the world
but every other example that you look at
be at Logitech Wacom or again a wish
product that's real cheap and nasty they
all come with the similar charging
cables that you actually have to plug
them in and plug them into a wall
charger whereas with the Apple pencil
you can simply just plug it into the
bottom of the Apple device and it will
charge on the go or just sitting at your
desk
I think this relatively simple feature
that's been implemented into the Apple
pencil first generation at least is
something that kind of persuades people
to purchase it when they do start
looking into alternatives for the Apple
pencil if on the other hand you're
comparing an Apple second-generation
pencil to potentially any other stylist
out there in the market I think you
really have to reconsider your choices
by going out and looking at a different
option with the Apple second-generation
pencil you have all the cons from the
first generation fixed up and made 10
times better
there's no more little lid at the end
that comes off and you can lose very
quickly very easily it's very flimsy and
it's not very fantastic and you also
don't have this simple rolling problem
when you lay it flat it comes with a
flat edge on one side which allows you
to place it simply on a surface or
magnetically connected to the iPad Pro
and charge at the same time
so overall guys what's my opinion on
these Apple pencils I think yes they are
completely overpriced products I don't
think they're warrant the 200 Australian
dollar price day that they come with but
at the same time I don't think there is
a competitor out there that is even
close to having all the features and all
the little bells and whistles that the
Apple pencil one and the Apple pencil to
come with so if you're somebody out
there that is looking to take notes
every single day looking to draw
potentially every single day or edit in
apps like Lightroom Photoshop
Illustrator anything like that that
requires finesse and pinpoint precision
then I think
you should definitely go out and invest
in an Apple pencil if you're just an
average user doing some quick emails
potentially watching some YouTube videos
then I don't think you really need to go
out and spend the additional $200 on an
Apple pencil when you can go out and
spend 20 30 $40 on your generic stylus
for the iPad and even in that situation
most of the time I don't actually
believe that a stylus is required for me
personally I do a lot of architecture so
I have to do lots of measurements lots
of drawings lots of markups on pages and
having a pencil is a very useful tool
whereas if I was just doing a general
day-to-day tasks you wouldn't really
need a stylus to work properly and you'd
probably find it less productive for
most people and that's all I have for
you guys today thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video smash
that subscribe button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday